this is a production of cornell
university
i just wanted to start out right away by
thanking my lab group and the funding
source for the
information i'm going to be sharing with
you today
so
right now in my lab i have ruth gender
who runs a program for organic farmers
out of my group
very independently
but she lets me be a part of it too
sometimes and then my students jenna
lynn eric anna christina
iselle and christina who
um four of them are working on bacterial
related projects and then anna christina
is our vibrologist right now
and then um
i also wanted to thank uh well really
all the staff but particularly andy
whether albert webber fred hathner and
keith heinz and who are in our seed
potato program because
they also help a lot when we want
samples collected in a certain way they
help us rate field plots and things like
that
so i wanted to start out talking
actually about the seed program and then
to introduce the pathogen it's that
group that i'm going to be describing
today and to show you
how
why we're interested in it
is this
it is not okay
so i
i'm located in madison
most of our commercial potatoes are
grown in the central sands right here
and then our seed growers are up in
anago here and then the university farm
is on the rhinelander there's a highway
that just runs straight up and down so i
spent a lot of my time driving up and
down that road
and things basically
like everything they run downhill i
guess so the potato seed potatoes grown
in ryland are sold to anago those are
generally sold everywhere south
and the other key thing that's going on
in wisconsin is the potato germplasm
center is here at sturgeon bay so
the u.s collection of diverse potato
genotypes is easily accessible right
there
and then this is the farm
it's about a thousand acres so it's
actually larger than the madison campus
it's mostly woods and a couple of lakes
we have four greenhouses about 100 acres
90 acres of potatoes every year and it's
a three year rotation and we tend to
irrigate out of this lake here
and it's a really beautiful place to
visit there's a lot of wildlife um i've
been followed by wolves we see bears
um
and so i stole all those pictures from
national geographic and they didn't have
the really important wildlife that we
have
up at the farm they didn't have any
photos of these guys but when i first
started i was interested
i was trained as a bacteriologist in
alan's lab so i wanted to work on
bacteria because that's what i knew how
to do
and i knew we had pectobacterium or soft
rot arminia in the lake and we were
irrigating with it it seemed like that
could be a problem
and then sending these potatoes all over
the country
okay so
how are they produced and was there
actually a problem when you irrigate
with water containing a plant pathogen
so everything comes up to that farm in
tissue culture um
we send tens of thousands of these
little plants up there every year from
the lab these should be pathogen-free
they get put into a hydroponic system
and we grow about three to four hundred
thousand mini tubers this way every year
these little guys are planted in a field
and what we harvest from them is sold to
the farmers to support the program or we
replant it and sell the second
generation
and if all goes well then they have
warehouses full of seed potatoes and
actually in the seed system soft drops
not that big of a deal and i think it's
because
they don't stress the plants for size
and they store them at a cooler
temperature so we see it but we don't
see it as a big deal
in commercial farming though it is a big
problem and it tends to either be a
problem right as they're emerging if we
have violent storms which happen a lot
in busan
or at this stage when the whole
warehouse will just rot
so
so it is a significant issue but not
generally with the growers i work with
we also certify
all the seed potatoes grown in a
regulatory program and it works out to
about seven and a half percent of the
total potatoes produced in the u.s
and
i wanted to
show you a little bit of this so i
realized just a few years ago with an
amazing we never throw anything away so
we have this amazing data set that goes
back decades
plus we have a lot of information on
what it actually costs to produce a crop
of potatoes and what the diseases
actually cost because we've been keeping
these budgets for years and we're
throwing them away
so we started publishing that
and again i can go back to these reports
and see
whether software is a big deal or not
and on occasion it shows up it's not
really the biggest thing we worry about
we got some kind of fun graphs out of
this so for example we can track
reduction in disease over the past 60
years
and reduction in human error over the
past 60 years in farming
so disease goes down with a
half-life of about 10 years and farming
the half-life is about the same as a
generation of farmers right so
it's about 26 years
and from this
data set that we from our certification
data it's just the form that they have
to fill out for receipt live
we can tell that pby right now is the
number one reason it's a potato virus y
is the number one reason for
seed certification
rejections and that's the basis for why
i'm really here today because this
project was stuart and
why i might becoming a me becoming a
virologist um
this really struck me until we put this
graph together ahead and realized this
that the other main reason for
rejections are mistakes that the farmers
make
and it's actually a bigger
issue than disease and really some of
these pby projections are probably due
to farmers making mistakes too
so i have become
i understand more now why maybe social
sciences need to be a part of what we do
because we should be thinking about how
farmers make decisions when we also try
to control disease or get them to adopt
control methods
the other place where we see a lot of
things coming out of the field besides
seed production is again ruth ginger's
program in organic
potato production so she works with now
38 farmers between ohio and north dakota
and we run variety trialing and it's
it's all very applied so what varieties
would work best for them how can we get
them seed how should they be controlling
disease how do you grow potatoes without
irrigation that kind of thing and we get
a lot of disease incidence data
soft rod so what this table shows all
these tiny little numbers it's a whole
bunch of varieties
and then it's
what percent of the lots from 2013 did
we have
a lot of calls off that field due to
certain disease so for example
adirondack blue silver skirt was our
main problem in most of our lots from
the farms we got data from
so soft dry is never a big deal but it's
constantly there so at harvest it's not
a big deal but when you're trying to
store things it can become a big deal
okay
so the pepto-bacteria bacterial soft
grout what is this it's
they're
ground negative bacteria they're the
enterobacteriaceae family so that's the
same as e coli and salmonella so you can
think of them
sort of like a plant pathogenic e coli
they're really easy to work with and a
lot of the tools that work with e coli
will also work with pectobacterium we
used to call it a winnie on carrot
topper or the softer automatic
so this family has a lot of human and
plant pathogens they often have insect
vectors they're really common in the
environment they're easy to
the family tends to be very easy to get
out of water and soil for example in all
the plants and up with people and cows
they have simple circular five megabase
genomes and they sometimes have
plastidines the the soft draw bacteria
that we work with plasmids don't seem to
be an important part of the story they
just have this five megabase circle
through their genome
and we've been grouping them
what we call the pdd clades so it's
pecto bacteria dichia and bernaria so
these three generals seem to fall form a
group of plant pathogens and
enterobacter you see it um
hectobacteria and nadipia are broad host
range soft drop pathogens so they cause
decay and wilt type diseases
and in
a whole
you know whole bunch of different
species of dicots and monocots
and then bernaria has been
almost unstudied so we think of it it
infects things like willow trees
and uh
walnut trees and then recently
cantaloupe has been about to be a host
and we don't tend to think of it as
peptolytic or causing soft drop but we
really don't know very much about this
genus at all
okay so this is a typical
example of a potato that has soft rod
from the field and you can see this
spot right here that's
would have been what was connected to
the stolen or the stem that connects the
tuber to the plant and that seems to be
where the bacteria
we often see
evidence that they've gone in through
the stolen and into the tuber
and i also just want you to think about
this is a really nice anaerobic chamber
right so they've gone in they can't
digest the skin
right there so they've got their own
little protective food source of the
soil that they're not sharing with
anybody
so you get very high concentrations of
bacteria here
okay
so i wanted to emphasize that these are
broad ostrage necrotropes and so i'm
guessing there's a lot of people here in
this audience and a lot about
pseudomonas syringes so
please don't try to make this fit this
is a stringy model um
we get this a lot when we try to submit
papers um
so they
we don't have examples of gene for gene
resistance for example that we know of
the least
we don't have evidence that these
pathogens are suppressing plant defenses
in fact they seem to perhaps induce cell
death and benefit from that
and they do cause cell death
so it's very different from pseudomonas
ringi which there's lots of examples of
g for g resistance they are very active
in suppressing plant defenses and they
do cause cell death eventually but
that's not what happens first
i also wanted to point out this symptom
because it's one that i
hadn't really appreciated until i
started working with this the first
thing that these guys do is trying to
plant yellow
like that so you can see that in the
field as like a bright yellow spot
and then the plant
dies okay
so where are they in the plant
they seem to
be very good at colonizing the vascular
system specifically the xylem so this is
just a potato stem that's been
inoculated with gfp-labeled bacteria
and i'll show you in a second why we
think those are xylo and you can see
this in field samples too the xylem will
turn black
and the center part of the stem will
also turn black and then the bacteria
are in between the cells too so
that this is a stem cut
longitudinally and here's the bacteria
in the xylem
you can see the
kind of spring-like
structure of the xylem and what strikes
me with this is the high density of the
bacterial cells they're really packed in
there
and that they actually the structure
design was still intact that surprised
me too because i thought of a soft
pathogen it would break down the xylem
but it's not doing that here
and then this is the
the cells within the stem and hopefully
what you can see is that the bacteria
tend to be around the edges of the cells
they're not just
necessarily um collapsing everything
right away
they do occasionally get inside a cell
and you'll see them swimming around like
crazy in these cells so that's another
difference between cinnamon and stringy
and
which you guys are probably more
familiar with effective bacteria these
guys tend to be modal in the plant they
cut their flagella and they're swimming
it makes doing growth curves a challenge
because the bacteria don't stay at all
where you put them
and the other thing i wanted to point
out is the density inside the cell is
never like it gets into the xylem so you
can see the big difference here between
how much gmp is there and what's inside
this cell
all right so just a little bit about
what we know how these guys interact
with plants at a more larger level
when i started in madison
i had to switch topics and i had to work
with something on potato
and i had an empty lab and so the first
thing i did was run out with walter
stevenson and we visited a bunch of
fields and storages where they had soft
drought diseases
the entire time he was trying to talk me
to working on common scab and that just
seemed too hard
so
collected a bunch of strains and i was
just trying to get a collection to start
working with and the first surprise we
got is that
what we were finding out in the field
wasn't just pectobacter and keratovrome
or pectobacteria nitrocepticum which
were the species we'd expected to find
but we found a lot of other clades of
pectobacterium also causing disease
so these are examples of what we
commonly find so pectobacter and
cartogram heretobrum
are subspecies brazilians or subspecies
are different or pectobacterium wasabi
which until then we thought was a
pathogen of wasabi and hot potato
we haven't found pectoral bacteria
nitroceptive yet in wisconsin i think
it's because our summers are so hot
it doesn't survive
but the take-home point here is that
multiple species tend to be present in a
field and sometimes in a plant
and so what we've done then in our lab
group is we're trying to focus less on
the things that differ between the
species and more on what does that genus
have in common
since we're going to find
multiple
species within a field anyway
okay so
this is just a representation of a
phylogenetic tree and that's to remind
me to tell you that i work very closely
with a couple researchers at uw campus
and one of them is nicole perna who's
about very interested in bioinformatics
and in the evolution of this bacterial
family and alan is the one who
introduced us and it's been so thank you
um we've been working together we both
started with uw and about the same time
and so a lot of what i'm going to tell
you about today is from this
collaboration
so one of the things nicole did was she
sequenced a big chunk of our culture
collection
she had money from biofuels
money
and i'm not sure you can defend the
choice of sequencing soft drop bacteria
for biofuels research but i was happy
she did it and
all of these genome sequences went into
her database so this is publicly
available
and each
each
gene in each microbe has its own page
and you can get the sequence the protein
sequence the math where that g is this
is her belt which is a regulator for the
type 3 secretion system and then
everything we know about that gene that
people have bothered to put in so
motifs publications related to that gene
and all the other homologs within the
database you can quickly link to
so this has been really valuable for us
and i wanted to show you a few things
that we've been doing with this and this
this is where this 300 genome title came
from so we've been using doing an
analysis of 307 of the genomes that are
in here and annotated
so some of the things that we've been
able to do
this is my favorite project out of this
we had a student bang
who developed a supervised machine
learning program to tell us what genes
were likely to be involved in plant
microbe interactions so we've got a lot
of genes with no known function and no
clear way to figure out what the
function is
so she basically took all the data in
this database
and
use it as a training set
and so i at the beginning of this
project didn't really know how do you
describe what supervised machine
learning is
and the way they described it to us it's
uh to my lab group was it's like netflix
right netflix will learn what you like
and make suggestions of what other movie
you might like and that's basically what
this program does it learns from the
training set
what a gene involved in plant microbe
interactions looks like and then it
suggests other genes and it will break
them so we made a training set with
dikia de deyoti and then tried it with
effectobacterium
and here's nicole and jeremy working on
this related project but
so
uh
to me it's sort of a
program that replaces the lab pi right
because now we've got a ranked list of
things that students should be working
on i don't need to tell the students
anymore what chance to focus on
and so this is what one of my students
is now doing is trying to figure out if
the program actually worked so he's
using the ranked list and trying to see
if he can detect that these genes are
involved in that micro interactions and
we're looking at all the
ones with no known function and then
he's just taking a random list and
seeing if the machine is doing any
better than just choosing them randomly
okay
anyway while we were working on this
stuff we noticed that these sorts of
papers were coming out so this is from a
group in finland
and they reported a pectobacterium
wasabi sequence and they reported the
sequence of their strain but then they
also included the ones out of our
collection because we never bothered
publishing anything on it
and so this was in 2012 and i called up
the call maybe we should start
publishing something on our genome
sequences they've been sitting out there
for a while and nobody's doing anything
and
you know how things are we didn't have a
student to work on this project we were
both busy with other things so a year
later she sends me this email
which is all you're supposed to see here
is that it's really really long
but this is the key like part of this
email says i have some data for you to
mull over in your spare time
and my hope is that you will look at
these and have immediate and profound
insights and evolutionary innovations in
this clade um she was of course joking
there
and then here was the key part you might
want to stop reading now and so that's
what i did and i put this away for two
months because it was so long and the
file that she sent was so complicated i
just could not deal with it
but then we had a really really cold
winter in wisconsin there wasn't much
that anybody could do so i finally
opened it up again in january
and she had set this excel file
that had all these extensive comparisons
between 307 genomes and she wanted to
know
could we make a story out of this
and so i spent the next six months
looking at this trying to figure out
what
did it mean
and so
what would you do with this kind of
comparison so my background again it's
more mutating genes and looking at the
biology of things and not in
bioinformatics so i felt like i was a
first year grad student trying to figure
this out
i use this this mural here's inspiration
a lot for what we do in the lab so is
there is there are there any medicine
people do you guys recognize this
no okay
this is the mifflin street co-op the old
co-op and this is a mural that's painted
of the idealized food system that they
were trying to create um
and uh
it's it's an example of where you would
find enterobacteria in the environment
too right it's everywhere it's in the
water and the soil and the
plants we eat and the people
okay so we've got
genomes from this environment and what
can we learn from that
so we decided to focus on two questions
um
because we only wanted to write one
paper and
the rate we were going um and nicole's
main interest is
this this clade of bacteria that
includes the soft drop bacteria in the
brain area
where where do they come from what is
their common ancestor so we think they
were either
related to the common they have yersidia
as a as the next closest relative or e
coli of salmonella
and so could we figure that out we've
she's been trying to do this for the
last 15 years without a clear answer
with all of these genomes we find the
right set of genes to give us that
answer
and then i was interested in what both
of us are interested in can we identify
genes that were important that were
acquired by this common ancestor that
helped this clay become
plant pathogens or to become the type of
plant pathogen that they are
so and what would those genes look like
who are they
okay so i don't have a good figure for
this
tree this question that nicole had is is
it derived from a common ancestor that's
similar to your seniority coli and
salmonella because we don't have the
answer yet
it turns out two-thirds of the genes
support one answer and one-third support
a different answer and she can't figure
out how to do the statistics to decide
if any of those signals are correct so
she's working right now with a
statistician
to try to answer what seems like a
simple question
but we were at least able to get a good
um
idea of how the the strains within the
clade were this group were related
so then we we try to go after this
question instead so what genes are more
common in this group of bacteria than
another enterobacteria and that's a big
piece of what's in this excel file
and then we wanted to see okay if we get
this class of genes does it match any of
the other data sets we have so do they
tend to be regulated by corn sensing do
they tend to be expressed in plants do
they tend to be things that this machine
learning program picked up so we can
take this set and put it against all
these other
sets of data that we have
so one of the first things that
surprised me or i thought was
interesting is that the genes that we
identified as more commonly found in
this group of plant pathogens and
another enterobacteria tended to be near
trnas
and they didn't tend to be linked to
really obvious mobile elements
so
you didn't it's not completely true but
that's
that was one thing that really stood out
okay so i you know if i was teaching a
class i divide you into groups of five
right now and ask you to write a list of
um
genes that that are probably more common
in the scrutiny plant pathogens and than
related animal pathogens or
environmental bacteria and and here's
some symptom pictures i've shown you so
what do you think we would find
plants have all the green enzymes yeah
so that that was
definitely in the set
so that's the first thing
i wanted to show you
so this felt good i was we we should
have found the plant cell degrading
enzymes that are responsible for the
symptoms we see with this group of
pathogens and that was what got spit out
by the
database
um
it was really helpful though to see this
complete list from the the 20 plant
pathogen genomes we're looking at and
then comparing it to the 280 some other
genomes because it helped us figure out
what the loci are and get some idea of
how these may have been acquired
so for example there's 21 loci encoding
plant cell wall degrading enzymes in
both cledicia ectobacterium
and there's six in bruneria i was
surprised to see so many plant cellular
degrading enzymes and these genomes that
i had been thinking of as as peptolytic
of these six there's one that's widely
present in the electrobacteria aca so
it's in your sinead e coli
as well
and it's got hell w
and this pectin methyl esterase here and
then an uptake
system so
okay and the the other thing that i
thought was really interesting of these
six conserved loci that are in these
three genera
they're really diverse so there's a
peptide lies there's two cellulases
there's a polyglactoronics the pectoral
cell estrace and i think this might
possibly be involved in plant cell wall
degrading activities too but nobody's
looked at it it's a synolic acid
decarboxylase
and this is just one of these examples
like we've been struggling as we've been
trying to write this up how do we not
have a
you know 50 figures in this paper what
are the the key things and so i found
that as a struggle and i was trying to
describe this too but this is a
typical example of what one of these
loci would look like bruneria will have
one of the genes and then one or the
other of these
other two general will have several
other plant cell wall degrading enzymes
of different classes stuck into that
locus
in this case
for example indica there's three pectate
lysis
this conserved py and then a pectin
so
yeah
what that one is right now
and all the subsequent acquisitions
beyond these six um loci
tend to be enzymes that are still within
those same six classes with a few
exceptions
and we don't see like
enzyme types that are in one indica but
not pectobacterium they seem to have the
same types of activities although not
necessarily the same enzymes
so
okay
and we're still left with the question
people have been asking for a long time
what's the benefit of having all these
loci developments dedicated to the
plant cell wall degrading enzymes i
wonder if it's analogous to the story
that we see with the
effectors in the type 3 secretion system
if
the plants are defending against these
enzymes for example we do know plants
can make inhibitors and affect these
enzymes and that's how well composition
differs among plant species so maybe
they do need to keep acquiring enzymes
to
maintain a broadhost range
um i wanted to just touch on on this
this is a something um we published one
paper in this area we're still working a
little bit on this so
when we do these analyses some sets of
genes just keep popping to the top of
the list all the time and one of them
is the
this fermentation pathway that ends in
either acetone or butanol
and so
every analysis we did this came up right
at the top is something interesting so
we finally looked at it more carefully
and this this will tie back to the
pectin
biases in a second so it's it's a very
small gene cluster that's got a
regulatory gene and then three enzymes
that take um it's the mixed acid
fermentation pathway so it starts with
pyruvate and then goes to either one of
these two
endpoints depending on whether that gene
is present or not this isn't in all of
the strings
and
if you've taken an intro micro course
you've probably played with this
reaction it's
what the vogue's prosper
reaction detects and it's the way that
we tell if coliform bacterium like you
call it salmonella are present in water
samples for example
versus
enterobacteria that we don't have to
worry about that are plant pathogens
it's because this pathway is present in
a lot of the environmental ones like
pectobacterium but absent from the human
pathogens
but it turns out these compounds are
really interesting i think they've been
kind of ignored
by a lot of us so
they connect they're volatiles that act
as insect hormones
they inhibit the ethylene response in
plants
and they
are pretty alkaline so they raise the ph
and that comes back to soft
pathogenicity
because under anaerobic conditions this
pathway is really odd and the potato
becomes more but the environment becomes
more alkaline and the plant cell wall
degrading enzymes are really only active
at ph8 so it's a way for the
if the bacterium didn't have this
pathway those enzymes would be no good
right
you couldn't use them
all this shows is a this is just
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu